sarah mon psy je commence avec vous donc
secondaire 5 qu'est ce qui a fait que il
ya eu un déclic pour vous puis vous êtes
engagé mais c'est venu en deux temps
mais premièrement je pense qu'en tant
que jeune on est tous très sensibilisée
à la cause ça dépend si on peut
l'ignorer ou la voir si ça a commencé en
début d'année scolaire en été avec mes
amis je tiens dans un parc et la
question est venue de si on voulait
avoir des enfants plus tard et tout le
monde a répondu non avec l'avenir de la
planète sur coeur j'ai tout le monde a
répondu non parce que c'est sûr qu'avec
l'avenir de la planète
on peut pas avoir d'enfant on veut pas
que nos enfants souffrent et cette
question est vraiment riche nommant tête
et l'est toujours et dernièrement avant
les vacances d'hiver j'ai entendu le
discours décrite attenberg à la coop 24
comment j'ai pu voir est elle vraiment
inspirée elle me montrer qu on peut
faire quelque chose il ya des actions
composer et voilà on va parler des
actions je vais faire un premier tour de
table et après je vous demande est très
concrètement qu'est-ce que vous
souhaitez albert lalonde donc secondaire
5 également
qu'est ce qui a fait le déclic chez vous
d'abord b c'est un mouvement qui est
sarah mon betty est parti sur instagram
ça a été partagée immédiatement moi
j'étais déjà un pied en environnement
dans mon école je participe et déjà
plusieurs initiatives dans ce sens là
puis je me suis toujours sentie très
concernée par l'initiative de christine
berg dès que je les entends du déjeuner
vu ça m'a vraiment frappé puis de
pouvoir quelqu'un parti j'avais même pas
pensé le faire mais je sens sauté sur
l'occasion et jamie vous êtes à
l'université parce que les universités
embarqué aussi la fin de partie c'est
environ un mois dans l'ancien comprend
deux princes on établit une
communication travers le québec au
complet tous les sommes versées sont là
ya beaucoup de sujets de cette école
secondaire encore sur l'homme et c'est
vraiment eu comparses l'initiative au
début un peu comme greta l'a fait à
chaque vendredi voix et puis si je peux
le considère plus sûr les landais
pourquoi je suis là moi c'est un plus
pour la même raison
je voulais avoir des enfants quand
j'étais jeune puisque j'en veux plus
c'est le déclic va faire réaliser qu'il
ya par un problème majeur et l'autre
exemple la cage où je m'engageais c'est
que même si on a les enfants commencent
à comprendre c'est quoi
d'élever l'enfant où aucun en phase
chronique dans le monde doit ce n'est
pas le droit de croire à un futur à long
terme
comment est ce qu'on veut qu'il
s'investit dans leur école parce qu'on
veut qu'ils qui construisent
d'initiative si le futur pour laquelle
il se bat n'est pas garanti alors qu'est
ce que vous demandez de mer les gens
vont vous voir peut-être dans la grande
région de montréal un peu partout au
québec
qu'est ce que vous demandez d'abord au
gouvernement' apprécié à vous demander
qu'est ce que vous vous demandez à vous
et à vos amis mais d'abord les
gouvernements accord est bon de trois
revendications est primordiale celle des
plus transparents dans nos
investissements en temps à quai fédéral
et provincial dans les industries
polluantes
la deuxième est de réduire nos émissions
de carbone de 50 % d'ici 2030 et de 100
pour cent d'ici 2050 pour limiter le
réchauffement climatique à 1.5 de russie
asus est un coup de coeur énorme mais
c'est énorme mais faux parce que sinon
les conséquences on s'enchaîner et la
troisième est celle d'une éducation
nationale sur les étudiants en général
ou une sensibilisation nationale sur les
changements climatiques et d'en parler
davantage à l'école vous dites oui on en
parle ici et là mais vous voudriez
qu'ils aient une prise de conscience et
des cours davantage de cours sur
l'implication citoyenne le rapport avec
la nature qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
exactement parce que personnellement
nous en notre école est juste un bac de
recyclage qui un sac poubelle des braves
en essaim bacs de compost par exemple
pourraient avoir des toits verts mais
aussi d'aider fait des défis zéro déchet
et puis je sais une sensibilisation
générale du secours il progresse
correctement parce que toute cette
information là on la trouve sur internet
mais après c'est les cas qu'ils ont si
nous former comme étant un futur citoyen
du monde nous font peu comme étant sur
citoyens albert et jamie il ya aussi une
responsabilité personnelle ne sais pas
vous par rapport au gouvernement
uniquement c'est vous par rapport à vos
amis à aux plus jeunes plus en plus
vieux
il ya une responsabilité personnelle
aussi de changer des choses on le fait
dans la mesure où c'est quelque chose
qui va affecter directement nos vies
notre futur nos rêves ça définit toutes
nos perspectives d'avenir
puis ça va définir celle de nos proches
aussi par contre notre mouvement on vise
vraiment l'action souvent demandé
l'action du gouvernement c'est qu'ils
réagissent favorablement
kiki qui met en place et toi
révendications kassar a énuméré plus tôt
puis donc ses percées une volonté
personnelle dans sont souvent le fait
pour nous que pour les autres la société
mais il ya une certaine sensibilisation
aussi qui créée avec les éditions qui
vient de marcher parce que qu'on veut ou
peut il ya un sentiment de panique qui
est en train de se propager par le tous
les étudiants est ce que vous demandez
dans vos dans vos cellules plus petites
dans vos familles par exemple à ce que
vous demandez quel des choses qui
changent plus rapidement à vos parents à
vos amis quand ils viennent chez vous et
cetera dans les choses quotidiennes
ouais mais faut aussi comprendre que le
changement personnel créé notre ça va
faire du très lourd sur les épaules de
l'individu puis si on veut que la
confiance y ont vu qui est la motivation
devrait en faire un changement qui
croient au mouvement
il faut qu'ils y voient qui à l'échelle
du gouvernement allait faire les
institutions et aussi le changement qui
ce fait vous qui vaut que la relation
comme institutionnels et individuels
escroquent l'éleveuse cédé par le
mouvement
donc oui j'essaie de faire en sorte
qu'elle tourne autour de moi surtout au
niveau de la concentration mais ça peut
pas venir sans les destine n'est pas le
poids ne pas être porté par que les
individus bien sûr mais sans le
changement de comportement des millions
d'individus on tourne en rond
est ce que vous demandez vous à vous à
vos parents d'en faire plus
arrêtez diminué de manger la
conservation des jambes ça mais je pense
que les gens sont prisonniers leur
quotidien et puis les gens ont des
contraintes
je pense que tout le monde fait déjà le
mieux qui peut selon son niveau de
conscience selon les informations dont
il dispose donc je pense que on est
rendu à un point où pour faire des
changes pour faire les changements donc
pour atteindre a cédé 20 points 5 degrés
celsius ce qui est défini par le gic
comme étant le sait la catastrophe mais
il faut qu'on adapte des changements des
mesures importantes drastique à
l'échelle la société puis en ce moment
ceux qui ont pouvoir c'est le
gouvernement donc c'est
sarah c'est demain on l'a beaucoup dit
est-ce que c'est aussi tous les
vendredis qui seront nécessaires mais
c'est un mouvement mondial demain
général
mais il faut souligner un seul vendredi
s'est passé cissé hebdomadaire si un
mouvement et demandèrent mondiale se
répète c'est là qu'il va vraiment avoir
un gros impact au queen ou secondaire où
s'engagent à manifester à chaque
vendredi après-midi dans vos écoles
respectives
on a vu cette semaine chacune des
commissions scolaires a dit c'est très
bien il faut que les parents signent des
des led pour vous permettre parce qu'ils
peuvent pas annuler les cours tous les
vendredis ou mai mais il faut comprendre
la situation complexe dans lequel les
étudiants y sont aussi les élèves qui
ont été suspendu récemment pour ça ouais
c'est d'un côté sud
comme dit vraiment il faut comprendre
qu'il ait consenti à un point parce que
c'est sentimental émotionnelle qui prend
les trouve t on voit les problèmes
critiques ce qui concerne plus populaire
à cause de ça avec les élèves au
secondaire se bat pour se battre pour
vraiment leur vie mais de l'autre côté
de l'institut qui leur dit on vous donne
pour les serments le droit de faire ce
pour l'instant pression de nos les
retenue mais dans le fond nous on veut
une pression sur le gouvernement
donc je pense que la pression de la part
de la commission scolaire les peu mise à
la même place
en même temps il ya un système scolaire
il ya des enseignements à fait résidera
liliane logique on peut pas mettre au
panier nécessairement vous la comprenez
où on la comprend certainement nos coûts
et notre éducation est primordial on
veut avoir une éducation et on veut
avoir une année aussi
par contre de cinq pieds de cette façon
là ça fait aussi partie de ce qu'on peut
appeler de l'éducation dans la mesure où
ça nous forme à quelque chose ça nous
force à nous un pion à société ça ne
forment à penser ça je viens seul paquet
de gens qui ont été sensibles à travers
cette si on veut pas demandé la
permission non plus de ne plus être
dérangé c'est d'attirer l'attention et
vous pourrez dire à vos professeurs ou à
vos parents que la ministre de
l'environnement aujourd'hui madame et
canet a dit j'espère qu'ils vont
manifester j'espère qu'ils ne
s'arrêteront pas là et on a besoin que
les jeunes dans nos sociétés manifeste
si vous le faites pas ben là ça veut
dire qu'on est un peu gelé
collectivement puis qu'on réagit à rien
merci d'être venu sur le plateau on va
suivre ça donc je demain si ou ça prend
le départ ou en mode 2d rien c'est au
mans
mon georges étienne cartier on bat du
mont royal et pour les prochains
vendredis qui vont suivre c'est entre au
parc jeanne mance entre le coin exploit
landais mont royal
très bien merci d'être venu à vous trois
sur le plateau merci on va suivre ce
mouvement là avec beaucoup d'intérêt